[Applause]
[Applause]
hi
guys oh thanks for hanging out with us
can i just share something and be
totally
honest i am rocking the caffeine this
morning
because i pulled an all-nighter with my
daughter frankie
yep she i know she poor little sausage
she was in total discomfort and she
couldn't go to the bathroom and frankie
i so apologize to your future self for
telling this story
but i didn't know how to get around it i
was like i should just tell the truth so
basically around 9 pm the pain started
and you cut to
9 38 p.m and we're in one bathroom and
i'm like
frankie honey it's going to be okay just
don't push because it's going to hurt
more you just got to relax your body and
i have
got you cut to 10 26 i administer motrin
1108 she accuses me of not giving her
real medicine
so i swear to her that the makers of
motrin have got her
back and at 102 am we're now in the
other bathroom and i'm hovering over her
still calm once again telling her don't
push
it's going to be okay and around 1 30
4 43 i'm sitting on the bathroom floor
this time like don't
push it just don't push him
307 a.m you want to watch hocus pocus
and at 309 she says mom i'm cold so i
wrap her in a bunch of blankets on the
couch
and then at 3 17 she says mom i need
more room on the couch
and i'm like totally hanging off of it
like okay
328 mom i'm still cold and i give her my
one last blanket that's tiny and as i
sit there freezing i look at her and i
think
i wouldn't have it any other way
and the good news is it turns out this
morning she's feeling great
precious to daisy apparently no
discomfort whatsoever so
good news virtual friends who's in the
all-nighters club with their kids
katie and lucy hi hey
that's really high true oh mothers and
daughters i love it how are you guys
good a big mommy hug to you
we all feel your pain but we know
sickness or no sickness being a mom you
never get me sleep so
you know we all feel your pain this
morning
thank you so much and i'll bless you to
you and your
gorgeous daughter and it's true we'll do
anything for our kids
and sometimes we just have to be honest
about it instead of coming out here and
pretending to be perfect all the time
i'm like i haven't slept i feel nuts
let's do this you guys are rock stars
you know and you do feel like a rock
star when you pull an all-nighter
just in a totally different way
and speaking of rock star moms gabrielle
union is on the show today
oh we love her and now let's kick it off
with
some drew's news
[Applause]
excuse me sir ma'am guy
tell me your story
ma'am i asked you a question
this is drew's news
this is true's news it's drew's news
every day our team we come up with
headlines to find
stories that simply made us happy and
let's see what
made the papers okay
you know sometimes you just read a story
and you're like yes
i love humanity and this one did that
for me it also made me hungry okay
i saw it this morning traveling leisure
reports
that there's a new record for world's
largest chocolate fountain
it's a 30-foot cascade of melted
chocolate falling into a big old lindor
oh yes give it to me i love sweet but
i'm also maybe thinking
nacho cheese might be better too i don't
know
hey virtual friends sweet or savory
samantha
which one floats your boat
me and the girls here we choose both
chocolate covered pretzels
i think like pretzels and chocolate and
nacho teas i would get like a little
tostitos scoop
and uh rocket thanks samantha
okay well good work lint you made the
world happy
and if chocolate fountains aren't your
thing can i interest you in a
wine backpack you heard me fox news
reports that boxed wine maker franzia
has just developed a backpack that
doubles as a wine dispenser
uh-huh a crucial accessory for any
merlot lover on the go
merlot on the go franzia also announced
swimsuits boxer shorts socks and other
accessories i mean
you guys can you imagine an entire
outfit made out of franzia products
it's like who are you wearing
it's franzia by franzia
i feel like you know if you're rocking
the franzia and draining that backpack
they're gonna have to come up with a few
more products like franzia electrolytes
franzia mattresses for the old pass out
and maybe some morning
huevos rancheros by franzia
okay so moving on this next story really
got me
according to a new study reported by
people magazine
who we love a dog's heart rate increases
46 whenever its owner says
i love you i mean can you even handle
the sweetness it's like i can't
it's me and my girls we have two dogs
douglas and lucy
that's them and it just makes me so
happy to think that
it gets our dog's heart racing when we
say those three little words
and douglas and lucy if you're watching
i love you
i love you so take some time to tell
your good boy
or good girl that you love them too
[Music]
you